one of his later Googles which comes in
so much like a day later he uh asked can
you be charged with murder without a
body oh my
oh my there he is I want to see like the
very very last one it's like how to
delete search history yeah I like how
dudes are just dudes like he's like
searching such a guy
he's like did you get a big dog
he's running out of ice
[Music]
okay we got a story about a guy named
Brian Walsh who is suspected of having
murdered his wife and spread the body
parts throughout different dumpsters in
Boston he says he didn't do it he claims
to be not guilty on all counts why do
you laughing Nick because I I wow the
punchline ain't even there yet no it's
it's a good story the real heartwarming
story really yeah Disney classic no
because no sorry I'm interrupting
continue your brain I'm sorry I didn't
know my life don't give out the gold gun
I'm not gonna give out the gold baby
this guy's murdered his wife spread the
[__] body
oh
I've been meaning to do that so the the
comedy initial story oh no he says he
didn't do it he claims to be innocent on
all counts he's like I didn't do any of
the stuff
but then they go and look at the Google
searches oh this one
you know what I'm talking about and
these are the Google searches that he
made right after the time that she was
last seen
and they're really great the best park
is the time stamps we're we're gonna
watch it we gotta watch it no you know
there's nothing to watch but I'll just
read them to you wait we can't watch it
what is it you want to watch it there's
an interview there's it's just literally
someone else saying what I'm gonna say
yeah yeah I think I think the good part
is his face as is being said they're in
a whole courtroom yeah as she's reading
the records and we can show that and
it's people aren't gonna have to squint
their eyes like crazy no or you could
just read it it's up to you here you go
boom here we go and we're in
can you do that
until 7am
10 ways to be smart ten please like it's
a listicle
10 ways how to dispose the body it's
like a buzzfeed article
what can we go away
throw away doll body parts
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's been researching possible
look at his face the bostonians
floor
oh my God having to like keep a straight
face throughout that whole thing because
like I ha I am curious about all those
answers dude it's like he just was like
thinking and whatever he thought just
he's Googling literally that like 10
ways to dismember a body he should have
hit up chat gbt and he would have got
some real good answers to
where to search first dude I am
fascinated by this stuff dude that is
nuts and
the criminals because they get caught
right
what did you think was gonna happen
he used his friend's iPad that's morons
dude so he started he started Googling
like right before 5am and his last
Google was 1 20 p.m yeah oh he was so
he's been researching he's spiraling
hours so he [__] killed her and he
just started Googling I'm not gonna let
my friend my iPad for that long I'm like
that his last search was can baking soda
mask or make a body smell good
the phrasing is so good how long do you
think he had an Excel sheet next to all
this stuff
like I feel like there's just zero
organization involved because he's like
Panic Googling yeah for sure and what
websites are answering these questions
was he Googling and I know right was he
Googling with a dead body there or was
this premeditation
no this is after so this is like oh so
that's why it's like it seems like a pan
of Google because these are the Google
search that took place oh my God but
like uh so the last known side of her it
was like right after that how did he
kill her I chopped her up I guess no I
mean he must have done something first
before cutting her up yeah like shot her
or like push it down so I don't think
they know because it's all body parts
they found in different dumpsters you
know it's crazy that that other little
News segment that where the anchor was
talking about like you know um sometimes
you can't uh say it's a murder or or
clarify because if there's no body or
whatever there's no evidence in that way
but because he like did all these Google
searches it's like that probable cause
he probably could have gone away yeah
but it's like you know maybe just the
[__] up legal system might have helped
him more if he just didn't do anything
afterwards you know somebody somebody
must have either ratted him out because
that's a friend's like a friend's iPad
right yeah oh yeah so he was using his
friend's iPad it might have still been
at their place though yeah it was still
his IP address yeah oh yeah oh yeah or
pinging the IP and stuff just being like
it wasn't about the device but rather
like the information I I don't know like
if you're on that Wi-Fi yeah yeah yeah
my favorite Google search is how do I
stop a body from decomposing that which
is uh that was his second search
stop it from decompose yeah everybody
choose your favorite one what's your
favorite ten ways top 10 ways of yeah
the person who wrote that article too
they're like you know what would be
helpful for people like maybe criminals
or someone who just killed their wife 10
ways on how to decomp deep yeah how do I
make this more searchable for SEO
purposes like a police station or like a
detective is like I know I'm gonna make
this website for idiots you know what I
mean and then they just [__] put this
whole thing down that's like this is how
you you know dispose of a body anybody
who goes to that website it's like
that's a suspect everybody knows the
best way to do it is pigs you starve
some pigs you take the teeth out and
then you feed it yep you feed the Dead
Bites the pigs
well yeah that's a different story but
like it it's like a non-story story it's
like she she made a reference saying
that he was seen in Costa Rica on this
date but that report was from 1990
something and it wasn't even a it's like
a faked document because it says
Department of Homeland Security on the
top which was her proof of going oh yeah
look at the letterhead it's an official
paper but it didn't exist in 97. wow so
that means she's the Department of
Homeland Security happened after 9 11.
oh so then they're like that wasn't even
a department
whoa so she so she put that date in and
that's pretty cool he claims to have
received a document saying that like
yeah so with this guy how did they even
know that he threw the body in like
different dumpsters
I I think they just started finding all
the bodies and then of course they're
always going to make the spouse the
prime suspect and then they checked his
[__] and there you go and they had a
bunch of blood soaked clothes in the
laundry machine on top of it
yeah so at least they follow the
Articles these searches were made
between the time that she was last seen
and the time that she was reported
missing so it's like exactly in that I
have a good question body spreading time
dude no one's just like that good like
to to chop up a human body in their home
and like to not have any evidence like
no one is that good unless you're
[__] Dexter right like or if you're
uh or you're you're planning it all out
or if you're Luca magnata yeah that's
true who's that even then he got caught
right like
the what even then he still got caught
yeah but he didn't get caught for that
like they caught him on other [__] well
like the internet's loose the cat [__]
it's a great documentary I'm not
watching that is one of the craziest
songs didn't I tell you to watch it
don't [__] with cats it's amazing I'm
not gonna watch gory [__] like that it's
not it's not gory it's like uh it's it's
remarkable really good though it's it's
like just [__] tell me I'm not
watching it it's an example of Internet
Justice Done Right or like the only
example no police no authorities could
catch him or trace him but people that
had an affinity towards cats knew that
he made videos abusing cats so it
motivated them to try to find him and
they solved this insane like crazy crime
spree that he was going on the internet
sleuthing done right yeah here's what
it's it's really really good though not
watching it it's not Glory it's more
fascinating no I can't do it any abuse
the best thing is like one of his later
one of his later Googles which comes in
so much like a day later he uh asked can
you be charged with murder without a
body
oh my God this guy's
guys
I want to see like the very very last
one it's like how to delete search
history yeah
it's that one the last one's the baking
soda I like how dudes are just dudes
like he's like searching such a guy
here's how the timeline goes so he on
January 1 January 1 that's the last day
she's seen uh he told police that that's
when she left for a job there's no
evidence she left the house then he has
his first string of Googles and then
January 2 he goes to Home Depot buys 450
worth of supplies mop bucket goggles
tarp Hatchet baking soda [__] idiot
how did they even Trace that oh did they
just look at like the surveillance
they're like huh let's check his bank
statements they're like oh there it is
he's paid in cash but you know this is
one of the biggest excels though dumb
yeah thank God he left the receipt next
to the bodies total idiot yeah and then
January 3 he had his last three Google
searches which was what happens to hair
in a dead body what's the rate of
decomposition of a body found in a
plastic bag compared to one on the
surface in the woods he's meticulous
yeah this guy's probably like I'm
thinking about everything I got it all
covered honestly I wouldn't know what to
do I killed the like if I killed someone
accident or not and I would I do nag I
don't know what to [__] do it I'm
pretty sure you're not gonna do a [__]
ton of Google searches I I probably do
the mob thing go out to the desert in
the middle [__] bury something there
and parade
I got that's what you should have done
exactly everyone knows or go on
DuckDuckGo and it's Lord get it
expressvpn oh
[Music]